quand on est face à des faits
angoissants qu'on ne comprend pas
notre cerveau cherche à combler les
vides
souvent le plus efficace c'est de les
affronter la lumière que tu as là va au
début rester comme elle est elle va
rester fixe ensuite graduellement elle
va clignoter pour finir par plonger
complètement la pièce dans le noir comme
ça tu te rendras compte qu'il n'y a rien
à craindre on y va
ça fait pas peur n'est-ce pas
il n'y a que toi ta sœur et moi
est-ce que ça va
c'est pas réel
ça va aller
[Musique]
dans ta tête
il y a une chose dans ma chambre
toi c'est le Titi tu me crois
on te l'a déjà dit ça existe pas les
monstres grandit en fait
j'ai pas envie de rigoler là j'ai besoin
d'être seul
maintenant vous avez ces espèces de
troubles
[Musique]
c'est représenter c'est la chose qui me
porte vos enfants quand vous ne faites
pas attention
non tu dois m'écouter papa je t'écoute
explique-toi
[Musique]